we are less than a month away from two
pivotal runoff elections in georgia that
will decide which political party
controls the u.s senate
now one group of high school influencers
in the state is determined to make a
difference in those elections
they are beating the pros at registering
and motivating young voters
mark strossman joins us now again from
the atlanta suburb of marietta mark good
morning to you
how are they doing it
good morning i think for starters
teenagers just know how to talk to
other teenagers and so this group they
they reached out they worked hard and
they discovered something that
a lot of their peers now want to have a
voice in what's happening in this
country
and with georgia's runoff elections
coming up this group now has a new
challenge
underneath this suburban atlanta back
porch you'll find a gen z
wave of voter registration and what's
exciting to me what's really surprising
to me is that so many people are getting
behind that
back in september edward aguilar and
three high school friends
launched students for tomorrow if we can
embed a stream onto the website we can
pull a ton of voters there
they register young first-time voters
mostly college freshmen
across the country we've built our own
text banking software
our own phone banking software donor
tracking volunteer tracking voter
tracking
and they've connected with three dozen
grassroots organizations
and it just blew up tons of people
started posting about how many new
voters did you register
we estimate it to be about 65 000. that
number seems huge to me does it seem
huge to you
it's surreal for election day students
for tomorrow estimates they registered
18 000 young voters just in georgia
joe biden won this state by about 12 000
votes
and keep in mind younger voters coming
into the electorate right now just tend
to be more ideologically liberal
as compared to other age demographics
part of the group's pitch
good old-fashioned peer pressure you
know how can you be okay with this why
wouldn't you want to use your
voice to get out there and vote george
is getting ready to vote again january
5th
in two u.s senate runoffs since the
november election
roughly 23 thousand georgians mostly
high school seniors
turned 18 and will be eligible to vote
students for tomorrow wants to register
these new voters
like michael gusto i gotta have some
sort of input i got to know what's going
on
valerie panamarov turned 18 last week
our voice will be heard excited i'm
thrilled
but i'm just going to move this guy here
but edward aguilar can't
vote he's still 17 but he's still
using his voice i can still have my own
civic duty i can still go out there and
get other people to vote i can still get
people
interested in politics get them to
mobilize and just because we can't vote
doesn't mean
we can't get other people to do it
and today is the deadline to register
new voters for the runoff elections next
month
but anthony think about the impact this
group has already had
in a state that really has proved every
vote
does count yeah when you won an election
by 12 000 votes
65 000 looks like a ton yes mark i'm so
impressed
number one they they certainly are
engaging in strategy
and they're so smart i think when i was
18 i didn't even think about voting in
high school i didn't really start until
i got out of college did you all vote i
didn't no
the fact that they're planning this
scary i worked in my first political
campaign when i was eight
there's anthony mason of course